-You've had
such an interesting path
in your acting career 'cause
first you were in the Marines.
And then --
Was it after the Marines
you went to L.A. briefly
and then came back to Indiana?
-Well, no, no,
before the Marine Corps.
-Okay, gotcha.
So, you came back, Marine Corps.
And then, came back from that,
and then, basically, decided t
go and audition for Juilliard.
-Yeah.
-So, that --
I mean, I've met people
who've gone there,
and I've met people
who auditioned.
It seems very intense,
especially, in my head,
I always forget
how young people are
when they audition
for Juilliard.
-What were the pieces
that you brought to audition
'Cause is it three things
that you have to do, usually
-Yeah. You have to sing --
Or, well,
you have to do two monologues,
one a contemporary monologue
and a classical monologue,
and then,
you have to sing a song.
-Okay.
-So, I sang, um --
Well, I did a monologue
from a monologue book.
I hadn't even read the play.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
That I found
at Barnes & Noble, I think
-Yeah.
-Which I don't know if
Barnes & Noble's around, but
that's another plug, I guess
-Yeah, seriously, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You're gonna catch hell
from Amazon for that.
-Yeah, which is, like,
the opposite of Amazon.
But Amazon's way better.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, of course. Yeah.
-For the sake of this.
And then, I did the openin
monologue from "Richard III.
-Okay.
-And then I sang
"Happy Birthday."
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that was my song.
-So, that seems, like the most
right-down-the-middle choice
-Yeah, right, yeah.
It's a very intense versio
of "Happy Birthday."
-I mean, I guess that would be
a case where you'd be like
"I'd love to do a song
from 'Oklahoma,'
but I only had the one line.
-Right, yeah, yeah, right.
Right.
-You're part of an organizatio
called
Arts in the Armed Services
Am I saying that right?
-Arts in the Armed Forces.
And this is
a great organization.
And you're doing
something very cool --
a very cool tie-in
with "Star Wars."
And it's basically this Omaze,
a way people can go on
and donate money for a chanc
for this really cool experience.
-Yeah, well, it's cool for us.
I don't know
if it's gonna be cool for them
You're supposed to donate --
If I understand this.
You donate, and then you get
two tickets to the premiere,
which is cool,
and then, I meet you
on the red carpet,
which is not a place
that I feel the most at home
[ Laughter ]
And then I sign a lightsaber
-Okay.
-Which I'm assuming
someone gives us.
I don't think they bring it.
-Yeah, yeah.
That would be really rude
if you were like...
[ Laughter ]
-Right, right.
-They meet you and they're like,
"And the lightsaber?"
-"Yeah, you got one?"
-Like, "You didn't bring one
I don't --"
-Right, right, right.
-Seem, like the chances
you'd have a better hookup
for a lightsaber.
-Right, yeah, yeah.
So, that's what it is.
You enter, and all the money
goes to this nonprofit,
which I run with my wife,
where we bring
contemporary theater
to a military audience
all around the country
and all around the world
and has branched out into this
thing where we do
a Bridge Award,
give a $10,000 grant
to anyone in the military
to write a play about anything
We do a film screening serie
for, you know, student veterans.
It's turned into kind of
a cultural hub
for people in the military
-It's a really cool idea.
Because, I think, if you'r
independent in the military,
there are so many people who
have no theater in their life.
-True.
-And probably think that there's
this real wall to them
being able to access,
and it's really cool that
you're bringing it to people
and because I think, obviously
everybody would
get something out of it.
-Oh, yeah, anytime --
It is, you know, kind of
predominantly in New York.
And, you know, anytime a group
says that this group
won't understand a play
because of their real estate
you know,
basically where they're from..
-Yeah.
-...or nationality or race
I always just --
none of that makes sense to me
So, we bring, you know,
what we consider is the best of,
you know,
American contemporary theater.
But we don't need to.
It's not military-themed,
by any means,
but because we're people,
because the military
is comprised of humans
who understand what it is
we're doing immediately,
you know,
and the connection is made
-That's really cool.
That's a great organization,
and congratulations
on everything else.
It's always such a pleasur
to see you, Adam.
-Welcome back.
-Good seeing you.
-Adam Driver.